switch from sitting to perching being
more active so 170 000 calories a year
if I choose not to sit just in choosing
not to sit in a traditional chair 170
000 calories of ice cream beer whiskey
whatever it is you give a [__] about
convert that amount and that's free
money
it seems like your most recent book
where you've tried to break down very
fundamental principles that people need
in order to just exist as a human in the
body
relationship with sleep relationship
with Mobility movements etc etc it seems
to me like that's really getting back to
a nice basic foundation and that at the
moment I think is the trend that I'm
seeing as well that we have a lot of
information and it's all about
synthesizing that into applicable
strategies now I think you're right you
know this this industry of fitness
and we'll call it capital F the
industrial Fitness complex used to be
you know Global gyms and and big protein
companies and now it's like this you
know decentralized you know netbot
everyone's got abs and everyone's got
their opinions about everything uh it's
a trillion dollar industry and if we say
well how's it going we can ask these
questions well how about obesity are we
are we solving our communities obesity
problems or diabetes diabetes or chronic
pain or surgery or ACL injury rates in
kids
or substance abuse or depression or
chronic pain and literally every single
one of those is trending in the wrong
direction so
something this experiment we've all been
running
we have gotten really good in this
vertical if you accidentally slipped
into the Instagram feed I mean there was
this an article in New York Times last
week about are you being crushed
by Fitness on your Instagram social
media because Fitness is literally just
like it's like the rest of us the last
of us it was just taking over like a
fungus
um I suspect that it has confused or
muddied the waters a little bit and I
think hopefully we're seeing a trend
towards what is essential and what we've
tried to do in this book is honestly
synthesize the information we've had
from 15 20 years of working with really
good teams and really good athletes and
saying which hinges swing the biggest
stores A and B which which are the
fundamental behaviors or can we create
some Vital Signs and some benchmarks so
that you could scale that up into a
world championship or scale it backwards
into I want to have kids who are durable
when they grow up
okay so how frequently do people sit
stand and walk have you ever seen any
statistics on this
yeah it's uh it's not great uh well you
know the key to think about all of this
is to say all right for literally we
haven't changed much to two and a half
million years of evolution and
especially in the last 10 000 years
we're the same person I mean I'm a
little fatter your femur is a little
longer but we're the same kids
and then what we really can from there
is not have some Paleolithic romantic
model of we should eat you know
fermented and buffalo livers and it gets
a little crazy what we can ask is what
did our environment look like because I
have to think yeah it's important it
will be useful as a as an intellectual
exercise to sort of ask why is our
lymphatic system bootstrapped into our
movement system the lymphatic system is
your sewage system right it processes
all the normal wastes that are two waste
particles and products that are too big
to go into circulatory system
and that system is a bunch of one-way
tubes that's driven by muscle
contraction and so it's almost like
we've been evolved to walk or move a
little bit more in the day than we
currently are and what we're seeing for
example is that most adults are moving
less than 3 000 total steps a day and we
can find that now because everyone has a
motion tracker it's their it's their
phone so what we're seeing is hey
there's sort of this been this creep
into mismatch between human and
environment and now we're having to be a
little bit more conscious about seeing
if we can remedy some of those things
what are the longest levers that can
offset somebody that sits at the desk
all day
you know the the first order of
businesses to get Beyond like sitting is
bad and standing is good because if
you've ever had a job or you stood all
day long it's gnarly and it's a real
problem we have to actually create a
whole bunch of surfaces for people that
are squishy and we have to give them
special shoes and you have to give them
breaks it's complicated so human beings
what that tells us is standing still is
not good sitting still is not good that
we need to move a little bit more during
the day so
you know this isn't our opinion you know
what we've seen in the last particularly
10 years with the the evolution of
technology and you know when we when we
opened our gym you know in 2005
we were on Yahoo business and our staff
was like why aren't you on Gmail we're
like because when we started this
business there was no Gmail just so
everyone's clear so something has
changed a lot where everyone's got a
laptop everyone's taking it home and
what we're seeing is you know the the
demands on us have changed as we've said
and Harvard suddenly got really
interested in some of this sedentary
biology sedentary Behavior sort of
physiology and one of the things we
noticed where they Define is that
sedentary lifestyle is if you drop below
one and a half metabolic equivalents so
everyone here is into fitness and
exercising if you're ever on like a
StairMaster at a hotel gym and it was
like you can work out at Mets I'm at six
Mets I have no idea is that good or bad
but Mets is a unit of measurement like
an ERG or a watt we've all adopted the
what but metabolic equivalent is
basically how much your body Burns at
rest
and what they've said is hey any
behavior that falls below one and a half
metabolic equivalents is a sedentary
Behavior so you're standing
I'm perching I'm leaning up against a
bar stool with my feet on the ground
both of us are engaged in movements and
positions that allow us to fidget and
require a little bit more
body movement body stabilization
Recruitment and it kicks us above one
and a half metabol equivalents as soon
as you sit in a chair or couch boom
you're below that so
Harvard defines sedentary lifestyle as
trying to limit total time in the day
spent underneath one and a half at six
hours and what we're seeing is that
we're crushing that we're at like 10 12
13 hours a day okay
what about offsetting the mobility
issues that you have you're in this
c-shaped human position hips are tight
lower back's tight next tight shoulders
are tight
let's say that someone is sat down at a
desk is there anything and they can't
get up you know they've got a job to do
they're in a sales role or whatever yeah
is there anything are there any cues
that they can have at their desk any
movements they can do any little
stretches they can do whilst on a call
whether video maybe isn't on
um
yeah right I can't quit your job I have
to feed my family correct so one of the
ways I think is useful to sit about
think about this is that you're not
fragile and you can sit all day long and
go ahead and jump on a red eye take a
long flight you know go to a conference
you'll see that it's fine
but what we can start to say is I think
if we can give people some Vital Signs
so the book for example is just kind of
you can divide it into two categories
the first category is here are some
Vital Signs and when I say Vital sign
like we'd say like blood pressure if I
say 120 over 80 everyone's like well
that's not very good blood pressure but
it's not bad blood pressure either it's
sort of like I should pay attention to
this so when we give people objective
values objective experiences where they
can say okay I'm above or below that but
then we can start to ask what the next
question is and what we can what we can
strip out one of the my favorite ways of
talking about training and this came out
of some of the work we did with Premier
Soccer
is Premier footy is that we call the
session or the training day or the
whatever what the stimulus was we call
its effect on the body the next day the
session cost so you can see that if you
have an aura ring or whoop you can see
what your heart rate variability is what
your resting heart rate is you can see
your kind of recovery score your total
sleep that's really a a a very technical
version of this idea of session cost and
what we're trying to do with all our
athletes is say hey we think that you
can no longer outwork anyone anymore
that sort of ship has sailed like maybe
you could outwork someone in the 90s you
had your secret scroll program and you
outworked them everyone's working really
hard that that ship has sailed but what
we do know is that our athletes we're
really working hard on saying how can we
reduce the session cost the CNS load the
implications of soreness Doms anything
that's sort of important to you what we
find is that those athletes who are
engage in better behaviors that allow
them to handle higher volumes and higher
intensities over longer periods of time
they tend to make more progress and they
tend to be that work everyone eventually
but it's not really true they end up out
adapting everyone they're better at
adapting to the stimulus and over time
they have better results so that session
cost is really useful because suddenly
we can say okay you're a cyclist how
does that all the time spent cycling
impact your ability to access your
native physiology so if you're engaged
in a sport and all of a sudden you can't
put your arms over your head or you
can't extend your hip suddenly we have a
really excellent way hang on one second
we have an excellent way of sort of
wrapping our heads around what the cost
of that position is so instead of heart
availability we can start to look at
actual shapes and what's nice about that
then is that allows us to quantify
what's going on so ultimately coming
back to your question we can say hey I
spent a lot of time in this position
instead of taking the tack that this is
a bad shape or this is going to cause
you injury what we can say is what was
the cost of all of this behavioral I
spent in the chair and it turns out well
I wasn't able to take a full breath or
turn my head or extend my hip or I lost
some hip flexion and that really helps
us to say
now what are the behaviors that I can
start to fare it into my life and maybe
I can't do it at all maybe I can just do
it at home
and how do I come back to a baseline so
once we establish a baseline for some
certain movement behaviors positions
then this gives us a real opportunity to
start to say hey let's keep you above
that and now you can say oh hey I've
been doing a lot of sitting I wonder if
that's impacting this shape or this
position and that gets us away from
again that really specious and overly
simplified conversation of sooning is
bad standing is good what's the cost of
the behaviors I'm in does it implicate
my ability to access my range of motion
and Physiology okay so rather than
pathologizing just sitting down you are
saying let's break this down what does
sitting down cause the next day what are
some of the issues
you got it yeah go what do you think
sitting does
tightens the hip flexes uh
tightens the lower back in terms of how
it feels but probably actually
deconditions the back because you're not
bracing quite so much uh curves the top
of the spine because most people's in
this sense dangerous I don't think I
want that well look I mean those of us
that are standing up in this beautiful
beautiful position here
um shoulders rolled forward
um yeah and again let's let's just say
that your body is solving a problem for
you right let's let's look at that like
this is the position where if I'm in
this shape for a long periods of time
this is how my body is solving it so
it's so I can do this job it you know
I'm going to get into this position my
neck's gonna go ahead and get a little
more tonic because it's useful to hold
my head up now it doesn't have to work
it just sends the message to make it
stiff
the only reason typically people care
about these kinds of behaviors is why
what do you think why because they want
to do something outside of that
particular environment no I don't think
that's it I think it's pain I think
someone gets to a place where like this
hurts and the normal ways that I
self-soothe don't work anymore
usually I just wake up and my I cut my
hand off the day before and it regrows
right like what I did when I was 19. and
that's that's didn't work and then I
used to take this ibuprofen and that
worked and then it didn't work and then
I used to get a massage and that didn't
work and then I started taking this THC
to sleep and that didn't work and so all
of a sudden I think what I think for a
lot of people
we're not really interested in tidal
volume we're not interested in pelvic
floor function we're interested in hip
extension we're interested in hey I I
just want to go back to be able to do
whatever I want to do and not care
but you're absolutely right underpinning
that physiology underpinning those
changes and function
right is is some aspect of my body being
changed by this behavior that I'm
engaged in a lot and how my body's
adapting to that so
you know ultimately we want everyone to
hear
pain is a request for change so if
you're sitting and your back starts to
ache you should not think oh my back is
aching this is a bummer you should be
thinking huh I wonder what my message my
body is telling me and that probably if
I have some different inputs my brain
will stop caring about what's going on
pain does not mean tissue trauma pain
does not necessarily mean that something
you need an MRI pain is your brain
becoming sensitized or interpreting
what's happening for your body and
that's why I think one of the things
that as you said is we're trying to help
people kind of organize all of these at
different aspects of these behaviors we
always forget how the systems work
together and that if you're super
stressed under slapped alcohol fueled
you've been eating pizza I guarantee
you're more likely to experience a less
effective brain than handling your silly
[__] than if you're well loved feel
like you're safe there's a beautiful
person in your waiting room right you
know I mean like you can see that there
we need to understand the brain and
that's all we have to talk about your
nutrition and we have to talk about your
sleep and we have to talk about your
safety and your movement and then we can
also talk about your shapes
Okay so
give us something applied somebody that
does sit all day they need to change
that position as frequently as possible
they need to probably spend as a little
bit of time walking if they can or
standing up or yeah let's say if I if I
know that I'm engaged in some sedentary
behaviors because I can't help it then
the first thing I need to do is say hey
I need to move more so what does that
look like I'm not talking about exercise
if you get to the gym that's kudos to
you but the first order businesses say
hey where in my day can I control and
have some more agency well that might be
around lunchtime around breakfast around
dinner so maybe it's sort of the book
ends of my day and then the chaos of the
day I got my kids off to school and now
I'm just you know holding on tight all I
can do is try to walk more move more and
now when we give someone a clear
objective and say hey look we know that
most of the good benefits really start
to happen between six and eight thousand
steps that becomes a reasonable number
to hit right I'm not saying 15 000 steps
or you're a failure I'm just saying hey
we really can start to see a lot of the
good benefits of moving more kick in at
six to eight but if you're also having a
hard time falling asleep we might need
to push that to 10 to 12 to accumulate
more exercise fatigue on the other side
too we can start so that means for you
you're like hey I have to sit all day
long can't control that but I can
control the book ends of where and how
I'm going to move more just to get more
steps in
potentially I can also change and
reframe how I'm working so that I have
movement Choice maybe I can perch
against the bar stool maybe I can change
my workout environment where I'm just
going to stand for a little bit or I'm
going to take a call standing something
like that
but then we can start to say well are
there some simple things and inputs into
some shapes that I can put in that help
me maintain my native ranges and you'll
see in the book we have things like the
couch stretch which maybe you can't do
at work but you absolutely can do things
called split squats at work so get into
a tandem stance squeeze your butt drop
it a little low hold that for five
breaths we can put in isometrics sneaky
isometrics that remind your body hey
here's shapes that I want to Value so
the ultimate thing that we say when
wherever we're trying to restore
someone's position or improve their
position and output is exposure before
we get into some technical technology
before we have some secret School
mobilization thing I'm like hey if you
want to get better sitting on the ground
let's sit on the ground if you want to
have time improving your squat let's not
do a whole bunch of complicated things
let's hold have you hold on to something
and start to spend time in a position
that we value start to tell your brain I
really want to own this position this is
native range so one of the things you
can do at work is just start getting
into a tandem position squeeze your butt
and go as deep as you can and hold that
for five breaths and then the next 10
minutes do it again or what do you mean
when you say tandem position for the
people I mean something looks like a
lunge shape
or we're taking that hip into extension
look at Ben Patrick of knees over Toes
has done such a good job of saying hey
it's okay to have ankle range of motion
that's really what he said your ankles
are actually supposed to flex and you're
supposed to use all of that 20 and 30
degrees of knee coming forward that's
totally normal but now I'm saying hey
let's go knees behind butt guy and that
in this situation the thing that's going
to be probably most likely to be limited
from lots of sedentary time is your
ability to extend your hip not hip
extension standing from a squat or the
toilet actually taking that knee behind
your butt into a lunge or a Sprint like
shape and spend time there that's the
thing that we want you to start to be
exposed to more have you got any idea
when we're talking about things like
couch stretch which most people will be
familiar with and they can Google it if
they're not or getting themselves into a
lunge and pushing that hip through to
open up that hip flexor to open up that
that set of hips have you got any idea
about the minimum effective dose or
where you really you've mentioned
between six and eight thousand perhaps
is where we start to see a big amount of
impact for walking is there an amount of
exposure time and attention that you see
that is where the impact really begins
for Mobility as well I think we want to
always remind people that these things
compound so you know you're like I did
it once I have to do it again you know I
don't understand it didn't fix me so how
stiff are you how old are you how much
time you what are your sports what's
your behavior you see there's too many
variables for here but what we can start
to say is let's begin by spending time
in this position so how much can we we
fix it in so did you do rearfoot
elevated split squats at the gym
probably don't need to do a lot more of
that today
um but what we can again come back to is
you know what we start to see is in in
some of these shapes if we can just get
30 second holds we can really start to
move the shape and notice that I'm I'm
less pedantic about I think it's 27.6
seconds in this shape that starts to
make your tissue change on a Tuesday in
October instead I'm like hey can you
take a big breath here
show me you can take five big breaths in
this position and now we start to unlock
a whole lot of other things we've got
your brain paying attention you start to
own that position because you're
breathing in that position I made you
take five breaths there that's really
long it might take you longer than 30
seconds to get five big breaths but when
we move away from this I did the minimum
dose and now I'm starting to say
qualitatively qualitatively can I occupy
the shape and breathe in this shape it
turns out to be more effective
how much do you need to do as much as
you need to do to to get back out I mean
I I ran yesterday I have to run again
you know what we're looking for is how
well your body can adapt to the stimulus
I understand and this seems like a much
more holistic way to do it rather than
just picking an arbitrary number and
prescribing it I get that uh when it
comes to shoulder neck back as well yeah
what are the big levers there
you know when when we're
when you come to me with some kind of
neck pain or lumbar pain remember it's
turns out to be your spine just it's
arbitrarily diced up by us right but it
is your spine it's like saying I'm here
for my upper femur pain you're like um I
think it's your leg I'm pretty sure it's
your leg no no it's my upper leg I'm
here for so
one of the things that we try to do when
anyone comes to us with pain because
again that's what you're telling me is
hey I'm really concerned about my lumbar
stability under 600 pound squat that's a
different conversation right
um
what we always prescribe first for all
our patients is I need to walk more we
need you to decongest and I need you to
accumulate enough non-exercise fatigue
that you fall asleep and we can cut
control that number two I want to make
sure that you are actually sleeping
right
and number three I need to make sure
that you are actually breathing and the
first motion around the spine is not
walking it's not rolling it's not
squatting it's breathing and so the very
first thing we start to look at is how
well and how vastly you can expand and
contract these tissues around the trunk
can you take a big breath in your upper
back can you take a big breath in your
belly it's an easy way to start to
signal to the brain hey look at all this
movement here and also we can start to
upregulate the system whether that's
decongestion of the system or just
moving the tissues and getting them to
slide and glide improving pressurization
improving VO2 max all of the things
but what's useful about that thinking
then
is most people who are coming are to
talk about low back pain are starting to
realize that their hips are somehow
connected to their back and so sometimes
on internet you would think that the
back is just this isolated thing that
has nothing to do with so how someone
moves or how the the structures are
connected to it so if you're hip and we
see this all the time in soccer players
it was a it was one of my young physio
moments when uh a uh one of the senior
physios was like oh it's another Tail
Wag the Dog thing where I was like what
are you talking about they're like well
we have these really stiff young soccer
players with huge quads and big butts
and they just yank around their spine
and I was like well what do you mean
because they're so powerful they're like
no they just they're so restricted in
their hip range of motion and they have
so much available power that when they
go
the hip the leg drags the pelvis into
position which just Wags the dog so what
we start to see is this very powerful
leg starts to impose a lot of hidden
Demand on the trunk and what you what
you think is we need a stronger trunk
you know because that's always oh we
need a bigger transmission we need
another cylinder on the engine wrong
let's go ahead and see if we can just
restore this native range of motion of
the pelvis so sitting on the ground
helps restore those ranges getting into
a lunge helps to restore those ranges
we've got a lot of sneaky ways to hit
rotation from 90 90 to elevated pigeon
lots of ways to be looking at rotation
of your hips to help your lumbar but
with the upper back
notice that the first order of business
to get your shoulder neck better was to
take a big breath because that gets your
upper back to move more effectively and
now if your thoracic spine is very stiff
or less stiff because you're not in that
C position or you've got a C position to
move something you can organize your
head more effectively and wait for it
just like the pelvis the lumbar and the
femur we're all a relationship well so
is your thoracic spine your neck and
your shoulder so if we want to get to
the bottom of your shoulder pain we're
gonna have to talk about how that
shoulder is connected to the trunk and
if we're going to get to the bottom of
your neck pain we're going to talk about
how effectively you can move your
shoulder and that's why we start to see
these things in systems no system in the
body works by itself
you mentioned breath the James Nest has
been on the show Brian McKenzie's been
on the show oh yeah but neither of them
have been on for quite a while on the
shows about 100 times bigger than the
last time that they were on for the
people that didn't get to catch either
of those episodes when it comes to how
we breathe what are most people getting
wrong
we should shift the language from
getting wrong to man you're not fully as
effective as you could be so we let's
talk about you know Brian is
gotten so good at the Deep physiology of
of breathing the real technical aspects
and its implication on athletic
performance and I am obsessed with the
mechanics of breathing what how how
springy is your rib cage what's going on
but most people can relate to this
so while you're listening to this going
to slouch forward let your shoulders
round let your chin you know kind of go
up get a good hink if you get a like a a
crease in your neck fat in the back
that's even better and without changing
your position this is how most people
are sitting on their computer go ahead
and take the biggest breath in you can
we can measure that
you can breathe through your nose if you
want
now breathe your mouth and watch it's
gonna be less okay
now watch this all I'm going to say is
find a position where you can take a
bigger breath and everyone will
automatically organize not brace not
sequence they'll organize their bodies
into a position where they intuitively
can take a more powerful breath so let's
measure that let's make this objective
let's not make it Feely so all of a
sudden now you take a huge breath
and your diaphragm descends and your rib
cage expand your chest expands and you
were like wow that's 10x bigger than
that little pinche rounded off breath so
we start to see is well that rounded C
shape is less effective at maintaining
the Integrity of my diaphragm
letting me access the musculature of my
rib cage it doesn't allow me to really
powerfully stabilize or stiffen because
my pelvic floor isn't functioning very
well in that shape so what most people
don't think about because they haven't
sort of been had their faces rubbed in
it is a lot of the shapes we adopt end
up inhibiting a lot of our function
so if I'm in a rounded position and I
can't really descend my diaphragm then
I'm going to do chest breathing I'm
going to breathe up in my neck and I
don't know why I clenched my jaw at
night and why I have a headache and why
my neck is always tight and I always
have to beat the crap out of my scalenes
well it turns out if you're using your
neck to breathe 10 000 times a day guess
what your body's going to do it's going
to say no problem bro this is how we're
doing it no problem we're got your back
your body's always going to solve this
problem for you it doesn't always hint
at the best way to expand your
physiology so we're always looking for
choices that allow us to regress and
progress
and so what we can say is hey this shape
you're in works but it's not going to
allow us to progress your physiology
you're not going to be able to go faster
you're not going to be able to go harder
you're not going to be able to go do the
things you want to do it works for now
until it doesn't work and then we're
going to have to reshape so ultimately
when we put the body into more efficient
positioning the whole thing starts to
change yes you should probably tape your
mouth at night when you sleep yes you
should probably learn how to breathe
through your nose yes but also holy moly
you're super stiff in the back and if
your back is stiff and you're a cyclist
and you can't take a breath there that's
going to be decreased VO2 max why don't
we do something about that
how should people consider
cueing themselves to remind I'm not in
the right position I'm not breathing
sufficiently deeply you know we're going
about this throughout the day and for
the next for the remainder of this
episode everyone's going to be breathing
fantastically but in an hour in an
hour's time maybe less so and in a day's
time they've forgotten what they what
they learned from you what are some of
the things that can cue people to remind
them we've got to be breathing deeply we
need to be breathing into both the upper
chest but also into the stomach as well
expanding that rib cage sitting up nice
and tall
so repetition is the mother of skill
right that's what you know practices
make perfect practice makes permanent so
now you now you have this idea around
hey can I adopt a more functional
position
in whatever shape I'm in so if I'm
working at my desk and I have to sit
those all those shapes aren't evil
they're not equal the shape that allows
me to maintain the most Integrity with
the lowest session cost that's my shape
that's the shape that's going to impact
my biology the least over the Long Haul
so already you have this idea that we
talked about can I take a bigger breath
in a different shape
so suddenly now you're on the Peloton
later on and you find yourself doing a
Sprint and you're like huh I wonder if I
can breathe in this position oh I wonder
if there's a position which I can
breathe more effectively I've only had
that conversation with I don't know
three or four world champion bikers
where I'm talking about finding shapes
for them in the Tour de France and on
the World Cup or in the Olympics where
we're trying to maintain their
ventilation position or I have athletes
who are in the Wind Tunnel being tested
at Specialized and we're having a
conversation between aerodynamics and
ventilation this compromise eventually I
can make you into an aerodynamic Wing
but you can't breathe in that position
so you know what's happening now is that
as soon as you have this Consciousness
this thing can I breathe in this
position because fundamentally
we can ask the question or or come back
to this truism if I can't breathe in a
position I don't own that position that
was a great cook who I first said that
right the the one of the Masters but in
the brains behind FMS but simultaneously
ayengar said a long time ago nerve is a
king of the breath the breath is King of
the brain so if I want to tell my brain
that I own a shape and that this shape
is safe the first and easiest way to do
that is to make sure that I can
ventilate fully and maximally it's
almost like in yoga they put me into
these pretzel positions and make me
breathe there why don't they do that
I understand you and mutual friend of
ours Aaron Alexander are very big about
getting up and down off the ground it's
something that he is always telling me
to do whenever I go to the sauna with
him and I sit down homeboys in the
bottom of a squad or he's in a Lotus
position or he's in a 1990
what is it that you guys are arriving at
with regards to being on the ground and
getting up off the ground why is that so
special
you know I think even just till a few
hundred years ago we slept on the ground
we toileted on the ground we cooked on
the ground we spent a lot of time on the
ground
and again just like if we looked at the
the circulatory system and the waste
system of the body right that being
bootstrapped into movement
there is some thinking and really
proposed by a really brilliant person
named Philip Beach that one of the ways
the body Tunes itself
is to spend time on the ground
all the different positions that you're
fidgeting load us in specific ways they
make our backs round we have to load and
sit in this 90 90 position we long sit
where during the course of just sitting
on the ground for 30 minutes
you are going to spend 30 minutes at
some end range positions that are going
to help you work on your having access
to better range of motion and things you
actually care about like downward dog or
being on the bike and all you have to do
is sit there
simultaneously
I think if we used this idea of
retirement so when I'm saving for
retirement what I think is I've got to
save this much money every month so I
can retire on this day and I start
working backwards right I need to have
this much my retire how much I need to
say every month I'm training for the
World Championships what I do is I get
all organized and I start working
backwards from the day I need to be the
fastest human being on the earth and we
start to plan your training well one of
the things we know is that the number
one reason people end up in nursing
homes is they can't get up off the
ground independently one of the ways
that I mean I just saw this this article
New York Times last week that said that
we expect hip fractures to double in
this country by 2050. so in 25 years
we're going to see double the number of
hip fractures and hip replacements
because of that fracture hip repairs
tells us that in the future
there's a couple things that are hugely
important getting up and down off the
ground not losing my balance so if I
work backwards from them then I can say
hey it's really easy for me to wait till
I'm just 70 or 80 and be like oh I can't
do it let me go to a special class and
see a physical therapist and rebuild my
bone density and get stronger or during
the course of the day I can just say hey
I'm watching TV at night everyone's
watching TV tonight stop lying you're
watching TV at night you're watching
Netflix just like us
sit on the ground for the first 30
minutes of that show and what you'll
find is man I can bury that in I don't
have to go to some sitting class I don't
have to drive myself to my friend's
house and jump in this sauna to be told
I just need to sit on the ground a
little bit more and when we start to do
that you'll start to see things like my
back feels better my hips feel better I
was oh hey my Roller's right there as
I'm sitting on the ground and now I have
buried in this really essential behavior
of expanding the load expanding the
positions that my body's engaged in day
to day and I improve my movement lexicon
while doing something else I didn't have
to go to a yoga class I just needed to
sit on the ground that is how we
untangle this freakish Guardian knot and
how I respect your time if you like to
go to spin class or CrossFit class or
lift heavyweights let's continue to do
that let's not take away from that let's
just expand what your movement choices
are movement options are all I'm asking
you to do is sit on the ground and this
isn't just in one position it's not just
cross-legged it's not just you know sat
with your legs out in front of you oh
you're so cute you think that you're
actually mobile enough to sit
cross-legged and like low dispose for a
half hour you are not what's gonna
happen is you're gonna be like Mama back
I better fidget so I'll now go 90 90.
and then uh let me kneel oh this
long-sitting position is gnarly my abs
are cramping and you'll change positions
so fidget once you've sort of run the
course exactly what you're saying as
soon as you've run the course change
your shapes and that's okay
it's almost like wait for it yoga is all
about meditation in the brain and they
were like you're not flexible enough or
mobile enough I've worked enough to sit
quietly so do all this yoga so you can
come to this cross-legged position and
sit there for an hour you can't do that
you can't even do that you're like my
legs are burning my low back takes you
out of that meditation so let's use that
same idea of hey I don't need you to be
still fidget all you want I'm going to
look for a c table so I use one of these
it's a small little square table that is
the shape the shape of a C I'm going to
say I haven't bothered looking yet but
I'm going to look to see if there's one
that's about six inches high and that
would mean that I would be able to throw
a laptop on that and I would be able to
work away I could have an external
keyboard and mouse if I wanted to do
that my Netflix time genuinely actually
is quite low because on an evening I'm
doing a lot of dinners here in Austin
because it's like the most sociable
place on the planet
um but coming downstairs and maybe
answering emails and and doing that
whilst on the ground for 30 minutes I
think would be really great so that's an
easy to work in I was just in uh Japan
on a crazy Backcountry ski tour in
February with some friends and we were
at this amazing Lodge in this National
Park
and one of the guys started to get sick
and I was like hey I can't be in your
home I'm gonna come home and my wife's
gonna kill me if I show up with a cold
and a man cold right like I just can't
be in the same room so we talked to the
hotel staff and we're like hey is there
another room they're like there's not
another room available and we're like
are you sure this is a big hotel and
there's not many people and they're like
nope sorry
when we dug down
turns out there weren't any more Western
white person rooms there were plenty of
Japanese rooms traditional Japanese
rooms and they were like but look at
this guy they literally pointed at me
and they're like he can't go in that
room the reason is by a futon yeah all
the chairs are low you have to sit on
the ground to use the toilet all the
controls to the room are low you have to
futon the tables are designed to be
sitting on the ground and they were like
this guy they literally pointed me like
he'll die in this room and I was like
trust me I have this room so if it's
about you know not getting sick and
staying in a room what we're seeing is I
want to maintain your choice I want to
maintain your movement Solutions and
what we're really talking about is
creating some benchmarks that allow you
to start to rewild yourself to come back
into being able to do the things your
body should do when we wrote becoming a
Supple Leopard it had two objective
measures in there the first was your
range of motion which is non-negotiable
that's what every doctor every surgeon
every orthopedist everyone thinks that
your shoulder should move this much your
hip should move this much even if you
have a special snowflake Scottish hip it
should squat to 120 degrees maybe not
135 degrees 120 degrees
suddenly what we can start to say is
okay here's your native range of motion
here's the objective and then here's
your output which is when we improved
your position we saw your wattage
improve and your poundage improved those
are our two objectives so now we've
taken those same ideas and tried to give
them to people around these other
behaviors let's add movement and make
movement of Vital sign how easy
you mentioned walking earlier on
your I'm going to guess that what you're
going to say is the best way to get
between six and eight thousand steps in
per day is whenever you can get six and
eight thousand steps in per day but I've
also seen from mutual friend Mark Bell
some interesting stuff to do with
insulin sensitivity if walking after you
eat a meal that's a nice way to get
small doses in I'm going to guess that
if you could you know three walks of 15
minutes is probably about between six
and eight thousand steps I'm gonna guess
as opposed to cracking out last thing at
night before you go to bed uh a full 8
000 steps because you've only moved 500
throughout the rest of the day are there
any other things that people need to
consider when looking at their walking
routine if you know it's going to snow
an inch an hour we can go out with a
broom and just sweep that right off or
we can wait there's two feet of snow and
go out with a very different tool and I
think imagine I was like I'm not going
to eat protein all day but instead I'm
just gonna eat all 200 grams of protein
I'm trying to get in this one meal you
can do it it's just not less good it's
not as fun not as effective it's better
to spread that out over the day
if
some days you're able to get a 30 minute
walk and cool
the other thing I would suggest is it's
not really about just steps it's about
movement so if I can be moving and
fidgeting at my desk if I can have some
place to balance and change my shape and
put one foot up and suddenly the whole
thing is total movement and let me just
frame this for everyone when we wrote uh
um deskbound
one of the things that Juliet found she
found this online calculator that you
add in your weight and she discovered
that if she just switched from sitting
to perching being more active she burned
an additional 100 000 calories a year
100 000. I outweighed my wife by a
hundred pounds basically and so I'm like
okay let me round down so 170 000
calories a year if I choose not to sit
just in choosing not to sit in a trap
traditional chair 170
000 calories of ice cream go ahead and
Google what your favorite ice cream is
and then just convert that into peeps
beer whiskey whatever it is you give a
[__] about convert that amount and
that's free money that's free I didn't
have to exercise I didn't have to change
my diet I just was able to revolutionize
my body composition just by making
myself move more and requiring more of
my body and what I want everyone to
remember is that it's not even about
that it's about this is how much is
required to get your tissues to not be
congested I want you to be able to
handle the workloads you're engaged in
we have started having all of our Elite
teams and athletes walk more even if
they're Elite athletes and guess what
happens their tissues are healthier the
heart rate variability improves the
resting heart rate goes down they feel
springier the next day they have fewer
tendon problems and skin problems it's
remarkable when we think about
circulation decongestion that's what
walking is
I am among the group of people that has
been using a whoop for a very long time
and uh I've had Jill Jameson on the show
you know Mr HRV we've spoken a lot about
that given everyone let's go follow Joe
Jameson Joel Jameson is the man please
go follow him he's a beast his content
is so good
given that we're talking about Vital
Signs today one of the first places that
people will go to will be metrics
objective metrics of what their body is
doing you've mentioned blood pressure
and stuff like that today obviously
we're getting things like
um breath rate resting heart rate heart
rate we've expanded those people are
uncomfortable with that right sao2 I
mean my ring picks up whether or not I
was breathing last night and had lower
oxygen saturation that's bananas what is
it that you are looking at with regards
to the clients that you work with the
athletes that you work with or just the
normal people day to day where you're
saying these are the big Benchmark
markers that you should be looking at
you've mentioned blood pressure a couple
of times today so I'm going to guess
that that's one of the big ones
I
um want people to look at them the
behave the bigger behaviors we expect
blood pressure to be a lagging indicator
of a whole bunch of other things right
um one of the one of my favorite people
around this is Stan efferding the Rhino
who has done so much to help big guys
manage their blood pressure and diagnose
sleep apnea so if you're a big guy with
him he's gonna insist that you start
you're a power athlete you have to use a
CPAP machine so he starts the assumption
that you're actually apnic and not
getting good rest and lo and behold he
starts with that assumption let's
organize your sleep and then all the
gains happen all the body transformation
happens all the strength improves so we
can start to see if we work on these
Vital Signs we expect this independent
set of panels to simultaneously improve
and those vital signs are did you get
fiber did you get enough micronutrients
did you get your protein macros how was
your sleep did you walk right we can
start to say those things are some real
physical Behavior pieces then we can
start to expand what the sort of the
benchmarks include balance we can you
know talk about range of motion some of
these other aspects and lo and behold
what we want is to appreciate that these
things that we've chosen these 10 kind
of hinges again that are swinging the
biggest doors
you should be able to clinically
validate them against anything you want
to I want to row faster cool I want to
lift more cool I want to be more durable
cool science supports all these things
the literature supports all these things
behavior supports all these things but
then you're like well prove it I'm like
prove it to everything
I want to see like your secret scroll
training program is the best in the
world you shout it out all the time
about how rad your program is
take anyone from your program I'm going
to drop you into some a third-party
program oh you think you can do David
Weck come over here and show me you
think you can you know jump into a power
power if you meet or do an Olympic lift
cool what I want people to understand is
that if we are hitting first principles
you can validate them in any way you
want and we should see them Trend in
Positive Directions you don't have to
have like hey I'm doing this thing to
affect my HRV if I start using sleep as
an organizing principle
suddenly I start cutting off caffeine
much earlier in the day I start making
just different decisions about walking
and even about alcohol you know for
example let me give you a good example
one of my sort of
we're always trying to get our athletes
to be 10 out of 10. remember this book
is the same thing that I take in
to the military to the Air Force to the
Army to England national soccer team
like these are the same things we're
trying to un trying to figure out what's
what
but one of the things for me is I always
struggle to eat enough believe it or not
I'm always behind
so getting enough protein every day is
sort of one of my things that I'm always
working on for some reason I get full
fast I don't like I like you know I just
I get busy I'm like [__] I'm behind
so intermittent fasting comes around
right and I'm like oh this is cool what
a sneaky way for calorie control and it
works for a lot of people but here's why
intermittent fasting didn't work for me
right because again the Sleep principle
this allowed me to say okay I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna feed in the morning
it's super cool I don't I'm not hungry I
don't Bonk I'm fat adapted I can drink
black coffee or not and then but when I
came time to do a brutal workout in the
early afternoon I was under calorie so I
was missing a key feeding time to fuel
so that I could go smash myself in
training on my bike I was like wow my
times are sucking on this FTP on my
normal climb then I found out holy crap
I'm way behind on my calories in this
compressed time and my calories I mean
am I going to get enough micronutrients
to fruits and vegetables am I going to
eat enough protein and it turned out I
couldn't do it unless I had a meal late
in the day so now it's like nine o'clock
at 10 o'clock I'm like let me have
another meal and guess what happens to
my sleep when I eat a big meal before I
go to bed I sleep like [__]
so running that for a few days in a week
and I was like man this is not working
because my third party adaptation my
third party validation was the Sleep
scores was telling me I was sucking and
that my strategies weren't facilitating
improvements in those things and that's
a really nice way of understanding sort
of and ferreting through all of the kind
of crazy diet information we're seeing
training information we're seeing
what are the easiest ways for people to
get more micronutrients and protein into
the diet what are your favorite hacks
for that given that it's a challenge for
you uh actually eating more food actual
food so you know when most people come
to diet if you're listening to this you
may actually see nutrition as a way of
winning like that's a lot of ways like
we actually work in sports Real Sports
not the internet where I have abs that's
not a [__] sport sorry for the
swearing the idea here is that I need
you to understand that we look at
fueling as a real way of can I handle
playing division one water polo can I
play in the NFL fueling is a real thing
most people come to nutrition not for
fueling and most some people come to
nutrition because they got a bad blood
panel but most people come to nutrition
because why because they want to lose
weight don't even want to change their
body composition they just want to lose
weight they don't even know what that
means
and so what we've seen is the best way
to do that is to expand their food look
again 10 years 15 years of diet culture
go on amok keto carnivore Primal paleo
vegan right we're all fighting this is
identity politics so what we've
eventually said is and figured out in
these first principles this is what we
know to be reasonable protein intakes
you're very sedentary person it's
probably 0.7.8 grams per pound body
weight and if you're growing injured
want to change your body composition
want to heal want to do something rad
you probably need a gram per pound body
weight that's really our goal for those
things which again super reasonable not
1.4 not two one
we also found that through our friend EC
synkowski who is at optimize me
nutrition she discovered this thing that
a lot of the massive benefits in health
and chronic disease started to improve
when people got 800 grams of fruits and
vegetables every day
because there were so many
micronutrients in there and wait for it
fiber if you want to tee someone up go
ahead and ask you know lay Norton about
you know is fiber bad for you or not and
it turns out micronutrients and fiber
and protein that's the game and if I say
to you I don't really care how you do it
I want to be a vegan cool show me hit
these markers I want to be carnivore
cool show me hit these markers you want
to do it just because you're you're a
super paleo and you hate yourself and
you want to eat six pounds of broccoli
every day knock yourself out but the
bottom line is when we give people those
benchmarks there it respects their
cultural identity respects their family
heritage it respects their their
personal policies and beliefs around the
foods that they eat but we can now start
to really sort through and not say you
know I'm like hey carnivore you don't
really get enough fiber we know that
fiber is better hey and now you've seen
all of the carnivore kids are like hey
carnivore plus berries
right so so something we're like cool
Welcome to the the meat and fruit
micronutrients but what we've really
done for a lot of people is we stopped
restricting what they ate because a
pound of cherries is 230 calories just I
challenge everyone here to take the all
you have to do is eat a pound of
cherries not have diarrhea and you'll
see that that's 230 calories our friend
EC recently took a tiny cookie
right out of a packet of like 50 cookies
and she's like what's the equivalent in
calories it was three bananas so look
you know like we demonize fruit all of a
sudden we're like you really think it's
all the bananas and apples that's why
you're so fat is that the problem
it's not the problem and if you have if
you eat four Big Apples a day because
that's what you can get down I'm down
with it super cool I don't care
it's funny to see uh
the kind of flip-flop that's happening
in diet culture especially over the last
10 years or so
um you know and even even stuff like the
liver King is a good example I know that
there are a ton of people that I respect
Derek from more plates of my day to the
guy that did the takedown of the liver
King says himself he's like I you know
between sort of one and two ounces of
liver a day because I do think that it
is good for me so it's like yes because
of what you said like uh dietary
identity Politics on the internet
everybody wants to plant their flag in
one particular group or in another
particular group and yeah it's
interesting to think about what
Health implications are being lost
simply because people want to identify
with one group or another
yeah and what we haven't done is
recognize its impact on the rest of
society this non one percent people who
are on Instagram arguing about diet the
rest of people who are like well these
are diet Oreos right and this is diet
soda and I eat this you know keto
Brownie and just all the processed
[__] where people aren't getting fed
right like right now you know this move
towards you know demonizing meat for
example let's you know just we'll just
open it right up
it is one of the most like culturally
insensitive racist socio sort of
oppressive things to say meat is bad
meat is one of the most nutrient dense
foods that you can possibly give someone
and In some cultures women can't own
land but they can own animals and what
you're basically saying is no no those
women shouldn't own those animals
because meat is evil are there problems
with factory farming yes but even if
you're like you gotta eat organic I'm
like no you don't you do not we want to
put the most nutrient dense foods why
because in this country
we are so sick and so fat and so
unhealthy and it's not because that's a
choice people are making like if you if
you pin anyone down on the street and
say hey do you want to you know be
disabled and feel terrible like no one
does no one does but we again I'm going
to put the blame right on us and start
to say well how is our experiment going
if we're running this experiment to
transform society and remember our
hypothesis is sport is a laboratory
through which we can understand
ourselves it's a laboratory for which we
can it's a test kitchen then we should
transform our communities and transform
society and we're not so how can we
better transmute the lessons that we're
learning in sports and in high
performance and all this and actually
take those first principles back to our
neighbors and to our families otherwise
man this is just we're going to leave
everyone behind and that that's a that's
not the calling of science are there any
foods that most people think that they
have to to eat every day but in
reflection in the harsh light of day
they're focusing on incorrectly oh I
don't it's not my expertise look what
I'll say is
if you know one of my favorite books is
by Kate Shanahan right who wrote deep
nutrition and she's like hey she's a
physician she's like let me look at all
the diets from all the world everyone
eats a fermented food that's super weird
we don't everyone Cooks their meat on
the bone I wonder why they do that oh
why do they eat all the collagen
connective tissue why do they what what
is it about cooking meat on bones that
are so amazing for the human body why do
they eat a wide variety of seasonal
fruits and vegetables like you start to
see is there's there's good fats in
there there's fermented foods in there
there's raw whole milk dairy in there
right there's
so what I think is we've represented for
people who are like hey I need to lose
body weight we're like okay here's this
brown rice and this Sashimi chicken
breast which we used to give to the dogs
and then it's broccoli and you're like
that's it you know and and
simultaneously look was it with the
Kevin Hart movie with uh The Rock and
he's like how'd you get all big you know
he's like well I just ate chicken and
rice and I lifted weights for 10 years
so simultaneously we know that this this
kind of calorie restriction in
weightlifting works but that sort of
negates how rad it is to be human and as
soon as we demonize things like beans
because beans are dangerous you know you
tell people bananas have too much sugar
I was at a biohacking conference this
year Dave asprey's back here hacking
conference talking about this and I told
the woman in the front row I was like
Hey two bananas today and she was like
oh I should gasp like what about the
sugar and I was like you've got to be
kidding me I was like how many fruits
and vegetables you had today and she had
none I was like you ate an 800 gram 800
calorie fat coffee I was like what what
are the micro nutrients that she's like
none and I was like nailed it I've had
two bananas crushing you lady and what
is that like 170 calories I was like
come on I weigh 235 and I have abs
that's not the problem
dude it's interesting I found it very
interesting at the moment I've got you
know over the next couple of weeks I've
got uh Petra tear on this week I've got
Thomas Delaware on Thursday I've got
Dave asper in a couple of weeks time
I've got you today uh you know the
number of
different approaches different
conversations that are happening around
this at the moment
um I'm not surprised man you know I've
been deep in this world as a like the
most advanced Normie on the planet uh
for forever and I find I find myself
getting getting sort of confused and
overblown with the new fads that come
through as well yeah right
um all of those people are in their way
really like what I really appreciate
about Peter attia please buy his book
it's so important
you know he is speaking from this
position of being a physician saying hey
we can really reshape what modern
medicine is like that's a really
important voice and a voice I he can't
have as me as the physical therapist the
same way I can't have us but what we can
do is we can work from our respective
corners and come towards the middle
we'll never meet in the middle there's
too much work to do but you're
absolutely right and it's okay that
there are multiple voices with slight
variation
but El Wilson has this idea of
consilience which is the unification of
knowledge and what we should be able to
do is I should be able to take all of
the principles from Peter's book or all
the principles from anyone else and
overlay them on my principles and
they'll look they'll have different
language they'll have different lexicon
but the principles and the outcomes are
the same and if there's a moment where
one of us has some interference then
that's a that's a opportunity to say
well are we saying the right thing do we
mean the right thing or does one of us
have a type one error in our thinking
but otherwise what you're going to see
is you should be able to Overlay all of
these things again tactics will be
different language will be different
culture will be different doesn't matter
but outcomes are the thing so when we
get your ego out of the way and we drive
this only by looking at our objective
outcomes that is when we start to change
society but we have to transmute those
objective outcomes into behaviors that
look like maybe eat some fruit maybe
walk around a little more hey your
balance sucks and that's that's why
you're going to break your hip like
let's we can do this we are clever
people and I think
what we have the possibility now
is to sort of deputize
our friends and family who are into this
like my friends are into this this is
all we talk about you and I we've never
really met in person but I guarantee you
I can training is the universal language
on the planet I I've taught on every
continent except Antarctica everyone
knows what a push-up is everyone knows
what deadlift is everyone who eats to
try to get better at those things like
it's all the same it really is this
Universal so let's go ahead and take
that power of this sort of cluster of us
and let's reach out to our aunts and our
uncles and our neighbors and let's see
if we can transform our families and our
households and our neighborhoods and
that is how we'll solve this Global
Health epidemic we don't have to think
at a state level or at a national level
it's too large we just need to like
invite the neighbor over to back squat
in the backyard
final thing one of the longest levers
something that I had my life Changed by
Matthew Walker on Joe Rogan
five or six years ago it's talking about
sleep spoken a lot about sleep on the
show humans been on we've spoken about
it in that way when it comes to
preparing for bed when it comes to
thinking about sleep what are the
longest levers that you're looking at
foreign
is
setting up yourself for sleep starts in
the day so I need to make sure I've
eaten enough calories and I can stop
eating early that that's made a big
difference for me what sort of a Time
window is that typically 7 30 8 p.m
because I have kids and what's up two
hours two and a half hours before bed
yeah it's about two hours usually if I
can get we usually try to eat between 6
30 and 7 that's sort of when it works
for our family but sometimes I have kids
who play water polo and this doesn't
work so we do the best we can but I try
to eat earlier in the day than later
because just mess up my sleep it don't
feel very good
I cut off caffeine earlier in the day I
maxed up My Steps early in the day and
of course my phone's out of the room duh
like there's some things like that
um I have some red lights in the bedroom
that I think really make a difference
because it the red light does not muck
up your circadian rhythm so our red look
we have some red lights that we can
switch in our living room but we switch
to red at night not because and because
my girls are never gonna wear dorky
glasses so we just but they think the
red lights are cool so
I like to sit on the ground when we
watch TV a little bit but I do a little
soft tissue work before I go to bed and
what I usually find that that soft
tissue work helps me relax it's like
getting a little self massage that's
when I put my soft tissue work in
and then I go to bed at the same time
every single night or in that same
window and it's early and so keep and I
sit with an eye mask and I my bed is
cold and I do all the things I take 500
milligrams of of of uh magnesium before
I go to bed and those are my routines
and then I don't [__] around with it I
do that and with what Lane Norton says
is bone crushing consistency really
um one of our friends recently said that
you know you feel so terrible on Monday
not because any other reason it's Monday
it's because you're jet lagged because
you messed up your sleep because look
everyone goes through this time change
right and they're like whenever I sleep
my man I'm like you did that every
weekend you stayed up till super late
and got up or like you messed with your
sleep the whole weekend you're in some
different time zone so I think around
this sleep thing we are such cultures of
habit and I've been doing this routine
for almost a decade and I sleep like I'm
dead I get regularly at 90s on and all
of my sleep equality because it's the
only way I can get through my day
you would be disgusted with the routine
that I did the week before last so I
went
Austin to uh uh Vegas on the Saturday
morning four hours sleep after South by
Southwest some Spotify thing uh
worked all day recorded a podcast went
and trained went to the UFC's power slap
event went to bed on the night got it
first thing flew from Vegas to LA uh
went out for a late dinner didn't even
eat until maybe 9 30 10 o'clock at night
to bed at midnight hopefully it was a
huge stake in a bottle of wine two for
two no alcohol
um but two for two there got up the next
morning did another podcast then from
the podcast flew straight from LAX to
Qatar which was a 16-hour direct flight
plus 10 hours of time change uh arrived
there three days in Qatar then flew to
Dubai two days in Dubai and then flew
back to Austin on the Sunday so in eight
days I'd done 20 000 miles and gone
through eight time zones
um and then last week
that's no different everyone hear this
that's bananas but it's no different
than having a baby or taking a ride out
from work okay in in that situation the
key is we control we can control and
when you have this benchmark
the problem is thinking that's normal
and that you don't ever try to get back
to something that looks like what we're
trying to do is build in enough
tolerance and durability that you can
weather those things and not be
sidetracked for a month I mean you know
I mean and look we're not the same age
I'm almost I'm 50 this year and if I did
that in a month it would take me a month
to crawl from the hole like like I said
you're like the next day you're like
yeah I had one bad workout but it was
fine
the key is having some benchmarks for
yourself
so that when your life gets out of hand
and it may not just be travel and work
it may be disease or injury or someone
gets sick in your family or you have
some heroic thing you gotta do for work
you have the tolerance and you can get
back to that because that is typical and
I think what we want to do is say what
an awesome life next time call me up
I'll go with you
one final thing that's just come to me
here
when something does occur that perturbs
your beautiful routinized sleep and
training in eight thousand steps and all
the rest of it
um for instance I've gone through this
little period where I've got all of this
travel this weekend I'm going to
Manchester and back in the space of
three days to record five podcasts for
gymshark
um
or does a bereavement there's a
catastrophe
something needs to happen the child that
is coming up with the kid whatever it is
what have you found in terms of the
people that you work with of either
mindset reframes fun places for them to
stand emotionally psychologically when
there is a or they get injured or
whatever it is where should people go to
they understand that there are these
Vital Signs they understand that there
are these things that will make them
feel better and they understand that
sometimes life either through accident
or on purpose gets in the way and
smashes us to Smithereens
where can they stand what can they think
about that makes them go okay like this
is going to be all right where do you
take people mentally for that
we have conditioned people to say unless
it's an intense exercise session in one
hour and I meal prepped it's all failure
that's what we've told people right I
either like a monk and I train like a
elite UFC fighter otherwise it's nothing
in the course of 24 hours we want to
expand this conversation about what is a
physical practice and a physical
practice means I take care of my body in
all these disparate ways seemingly
disparate ways
in the course of that
three days what we can start to say is
we'll give you two approaches one is we
can say hey there are going to be net
benefits to my nervous system and net
taxes on my nervous system
so you you made a choice hey I'm eating
late but I'm not gonna drink that was a
really simple thing I can't control I'm
gonna eat and enjoy it but I'm just not
going to add another stressor because
I'm super stressed right now right I
might go out and say you know gosh
Julian and I probably have two drinks a
month and the reason Hang on we're not
tea toddlers we're like man we're in a
really stressful time in our lives right
now and it really messed up my sleep and
I'm trying to be fit and do a bunch of
rad stuff and I have to say to myself is
this drink worth messing up those things
or it doesn't mess it up but cost me a
little bit
you made a really simple decision there
hey I don't think I'm gonna throw
another stressor in but then you also
have to say well hey I don't need to
train because my muscles aren't going to
go away my fitness isn't going to rot
and right now I'm in these other phase
of my life but I bet I can get my steps
in so on Saturday where am I or Saturday
or Sunday I forget I met my daughter's
National Water Polo tournament right
we're there first games at eight next
games at five or in some
you know High School in the middle of
nowhere waiting around for these
waterfall tournaments so my wife and I
are like let's go for a walk so we just
maxed out our steps that day then I sat
on the ground during the games and those
are the two things I did and I was like
well I can eat fruits and vegetables
today and I get enough protein and I
check the box and I say this is what I
could control today and that's enough
that was my physical practice tomorrow I
get a whole different day to say hey can
I expand my physical practice so I think
what's nice about having these
benchmarks is that I'm on the airplane
and I'm like well let me grab these two
cups of fruit and these four hard-boiled
eggs that way at least I can be working
towards getting my grams in for the day
right and then I'm going to walk around
the terminal like I did in Japan waiting
because I got to get some steps because
I know I'm going to be still for 16
hours on this airplane and suddenly what
we've done is we didn't say hey training
or eating perfectly was the goal we said
I'm gonna hit my minimums I'm going to
control what I can control and because
I'm so durable and because I'm such a
rad being on this Earth that will be
enough today tomorrow I'll get another
chance to play the whole game again
let's expand what it means so when those
things happen you know I don't believe
in periodization hold on if everyone
freaks out I know pretty this one works
you're a Russian you're on drugs you're
tightly controlled we definitely
manipulate volume and intensity for our
athletes of course but as a as like a
middle-aged dude who's just exercising I
have to jump on an airplane and go to
York there's my periodization there's my
built-in rest so I'm going to smash
myself this week because on Saturday
Sunday Monday I have no control over my
schedule and I think when we start to
think about that I don't throw the whole
baby out with the bathroom ah [__] it
I'll just drink a bottle of whiskey or
you know I'm gonna eat whatever I want I
say oh here's the one thing where I have
some agency I'm going to control that
agency I really really like that I like
the fact that you can control certain
things certain things are going to be
outside because we talk about that we've
spoken about it on the show you know the
the stoic fork or the dichotomy of
control as it's called in stoicism about
the things that you can and can't
control
but you forget about that when it comes
to stuff to do with health and fitness
because it is such an All or Nothing
mentality right I'm either completely
dialed in calories are being hit I'm
training I'm getting my walk-in I'm
doing 180 minutes of Zone 2 cardio per
week and my sleep's being tracked or I'm
just like a complete hedonist slob
covered in Papa John's and and you know
book hockeyed with with Oreos so you
have this you do have this sort of All
or Nothing mentality
um and I love it a ton of that stuff
there you know getting a walk-in when
you're in the airport terminal
um you can if you arrive
at the suggested time I think like a
remotely appropriate suggested time for
a domestic flight and you're through
you've got an hour an hour is 10 000
steps easy especially if you're in a
good a good Airport terminal with a lot
of walking where you don't have to keep
on turning around so everyone sees you
every five minutes
uh yeah I I love all of that man I I
really really appreciate the fact that
you're simplifying this I think you know
even for me someone that's trained for
you know coming up on 20 years now in in
all manner of different forms
Getting Back to Basics reminding myself
that once I finish this I've been inside
for you know a couple of hours I
probably should go outside get a bit of
sunlight go for a walk get moving I
probably should come back and maybe
think about the protein that I've had
today you know all of these Basics I
think are a really really good reminders
and good fundamentals that are scalable
no matter what someone's level of skill
is someone's progression is and no
matter how much catastrophe is going on
in life as well
you can think about I'm going to build
up as many credits as I can I'm going to
spend the credits however I want and
sometimes I spend those credits and
sometimes the credits spend me right
things are out of control as you say
catastrophe bad things are going to
happen weird deadlines are going to pop
up you're just blowing through your
credits and you don't have any choice
and sometimes you're like we're going to
Vegas I'm going to burn through all my
credits and the idea is hey if we can be
consistent for long periods of time
really just do the basics it's not
heroic the all the things that we're
suggesting are small things that I want
you just to integrate into your life so
they're hidden if we look at the blue
zones no one there is intentionally
doing anything to live long the whole
world is set up so they don't have to
make another Choice the whole thing is
like well they got to walk to the market
and then at the market they only have
ingredients I have to buy food then make
food with food I bought right I have to
see friends as I walk there you didn't
have to do anything that's the goal can
we hide the Reps can we bury this into
your life so that you can spend your
willpower on the things that really
matter to you not on like uh I should do
this one hour yoga class like let's get
over that Kelly Star ladies and
gentlemen if people want to keep up to
date with the stuff that you're doing at
the moment where should they go
well the first place I would send you is
built2move.com we've got a 21 day follow
along that goes with the book so you can
hand this to your mom your dad your
brother and uncle and say hey let's get
involved or if you work with a company
and you're like hey I think we can
transform the health of our company
we're always the at the ready State
always around but uh mainly you know
when we see in public let's hug it up
okay I appreciate you thank you mate
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]